hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play the Attic
part 2 strange that I'm in the basement
now and is still called the Attic I
guess that's where it all started yep
boom right on the money
got it got it let that up yeah it's like
you sir
yeah yeah what hey what hey ah no no
none of the disappearing douchebaggery
you dick Oh
Mireille what am I doing with this oh
hello my guess that was it then alrighty
then fine oh me didn't bother me not
even a little bit right here I'm okay
anything baby you're gonna auto grab to
where it needs to go sanity potion
anybody
I got type that's where I came in okay
so who what's this
oh yeah if oh I see oil I see laudanum I
think in the boxes it's the mother lode
hello
give me that me ah yeah yeah big it's a
big and oh so big oh yeah I got a pipe
don't know why but I got it hello no
uh-uh
okay no no no all right no no no no no
no not here
you're a dick
get sewer key I know where this goes is
this the only reason for coming in here
chair
hey I know this goes I know I know I
know
Divac all right ah Monsieur key there we
go [ __ ] moving forward guys aren't
gonna get the best of me I looks like
sewer water
I should go splashing around in it
wouldn't be an amnesia custom story
without a water monster part oh there's
nothing don't ii i can see better
without the torch in this area lantern
what everyone calling
torch is British for flashlights or
something Oh support babies good lock
down there goooo face
there is it as much ambience in this
custom story so I would like like you
know I like music and constant reminder
that there are monsters everywhere oh
come on I can make that huh dick
this boxes here a few I'll do a fly
what oh crap I just had to ask for it oh
no oh no they're gonna make me oh they
can't possibly oh goodness oh they're
gonna make me carry my own boxes Oh an
ordeal ooh oh you're deluded get out of
your ass bag no one likes you
that's my dime over there dick ah [ __ ]
I'm going going screw it screw it screw
it screw it ah [ __ ] you I'm over London
Dunham my father's experimental bracer
that's just dopey of you such a ripoff
okay okay t-man they love their keys
hello a leaner anything on the table
hey dead guy another day oh why you
gotta be like that okay let's go let's
go let's go let's go let's go let's go
no no stop
yep oh yeah right off the bat yeah yeah
okay okay I'm okay
I am Hey okay it was a friggin padlock
still on yeah what really I couldn't
take the hint that maybe this was a bad
place to go
[ __ ] this I'm getting out if you I got a
bone I'm getting out of here now well
what do I do
how do I get out of here um go back up
why did I come down here in the first
place really why did I come down here in
the first place and there we go
what's the point of that
my fans make what what how how did I get
here I'm still taking your head I don't
care if you were falling down or
whatever
bonk [ __ ] okay that's locked now the
nice boxes are knocked over can't climb
up
that's swaying precariously I should
walk directly under it
okay that's sunken halfway into the
floor this tables knocked over looked
pretty good I'm gonna go now Derrick
it's your mother dear nope
ya don't need to keep running tell the
King what your father has done and end
this so there's a mayor and a king
wouldn't he be a lord then and always
remember we are all destined for good
things
mm-hmm
let's look 10 times creepier than
anything I've encountered in this game
so far I love you shut up I don't know
if that's supposed to be sweet but
really freakin creepy okay man it's not
just me right
that was like frickin frackin creepy
I don't know why but that was like
unbelievably creepy to be okay anyway
alright that's pretty good I mean it it
didn't have like the highest scare
points that I've ever I've ever had mine
I've ever played but I mean it was still
well put together I mean it was
interesting unique in a few ways but not
not a lot but I mean well chapter three
did I find all the secrets there were
secrets anyway it was use it Susan even
halfway discussing story it was the best
one I played but it was definitely worth
its own range pretty time but I'm that's
all for this thanks so much for watching
hopefully after this I will be back from
Comic Con remember this whole deals
Comic Con deal on that time ago so
hopefully I will be back from Comic Con
after this and now we'll be back to my
three day schedule so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
give me bye bye